hockey fans in Toronto and Edmonton are
waking up with disappointment this
weekend after both teams lost on Friday
night it is like getting your heart
ripped out
but it happens every single year and you
know it's about to happen it's always on
the verge of happening but you have this
hope that
everything's going to work out and every
single year it never ever ever ever ever
does and here we are
talk about disappointment the Toronto
Maple Leafs have been eliminated from
the NHL playoffs after losing 3-2 to the
Florida Panthers in overtime the Leafs
broke the curse and escaped the opening
round for the first time in nearly 20
years but a quick round two exit has
opened up many questions about the
team's future Toronto finished the
playoffs with a one in five record on
home ice
well the orders got after a very good
start and I think they were unlucky with
the penalties in the second period they
can definitely win two games in a row so
it was a tight game I think they played
well
Las Vegas played well but uh I think
there was a bit of luck that was missing
for you always and that's all that's all
they're missing
meanwhile the Edmonton Oilers fell 4-3
to the golden knights in Las Vegas
Edmonton took an early lead thanks to
Connor McDavid and Zach Hyman but it was
a three goal second period from Vegas
that turned the momentum around the
Oilers are now on the brink of
elimination down 3-2 in the series and
we'll head back to Edmonton for game six
on Sunday